- Oh my God I love you.
- [Kelly] Happy new year,
I'm gonna to say that-
- Happy new year.
- But I have to say this, it's so funny,
'cause on one of those times you're here,
my mom, I hadn't seen
the show that you're on,
and it was so funny
'cause you had mentioned
that somebody at American
Idol had said that you could,
they thought you were my mom.
- Right.
- My mom during Christmas
break, before new year,
literally said that she was like,
"I saw someone with Valerie
Bertinelli the other day."
She was like, "I feel like
she could be your mom."
Which I think is weird
for your mom to say.
- Yes.
- Like my mom said it.
But she was like, "I feel
like y'all look so similar."
And I was like, "That's so crazy!"
I was like, "We've had
this conversation before."
- I think I walked by
your mother after you won,
and she was sobbing as well.
- Oh, sobbing.
- Yeah.
- She was probably like,
"Finally, we'll be able to pay bills."
(laughs)
We're broke.
Teachers don't make enough money.
- No, they don't.
- They do not.
And wait, one of the times
that we saw each other,
we were at a lunch and you
were talking about your son,
and how he's a musician,
you were so proud of him and,
'cause it was big footsteps.
- Yes.
- With his father, Eddie.
So it's amazing, he's
nominated for a Grammy.
(shouting)
(applauding)
Congratulations!
- Thank you, thank you.
I couldn't be more happy.
I'm so much more happy for his success,
than I ever, ever could be for mine.
- Yeah, that's a mom.
- I'm over the moon.
Yeah, I guess so.
- How did you get the news
that he'd been nominated?
- I didn't realize the
nominations were happening
and it was online and I went,
"Oh my God I wanna see."
I saw Billie Eilish and she
was announcing the rock group.
And when they got to the best song,
I screamed in the middle of
my bathroom all by myself,
scared my animals, they all
went running out of the room.
But I mean, the first person
I wanted to call after Wolfie
was Ed, 'cause Ed was beyond
the moon, proud of Wolfie.
He, the only thing in this world
that ever made Wolfie happy,
that ever made Ed happy,
they're the same person, was Wolfie.
Ed just got so much joy
out of watching Wolfie
play music and be creative.
And it's, I wish he was here.
- Well, and also, 'cause
it's one of those things,
when it's something you love and you see,
even when I see my daughter
at a school performance,
I'm not the mom that's like,
move your, make your smile,
honey, I'm not that mom,
but I do get excited 'cause
it's something that we share.
- Yeah.
- So that's cool.
- It is.
- I'm so happy for him.
Please tell him congratulations.
- Thank you, I will.
- That's so fricking cool.
- I will, thank you.
- Especially at songwriting,
that's so cool.
- You know how hard it is to write a song?
- It is, it is also, it's a hard category.
There's so many amazing songs
that are released in a year.
And how do you pick the few
that are gonna be in that,
you know what I'm saying?
It's a hard thing, so, congratulations.
Also, there's some sad news.
I know that you were
really close with Betty,
and I know that you worked
with her on "Hot in Cleveland"
and so, do you remember
the first time you met her?
- The first time I met
her, was at the reading,
the very first script reading
for "Hot in Cleveland"
and I was in awe.
And when I, you've met Betty.
- I actually never met Betty.
(gasps)
- I can't believe that.
- I never met Betty White.
- Oh my God.
I know, and I'm such a huge fan, but yeah.
Well who isn't.
- When you're in her
presence, she literally glows.
I'm telling you, I don't know how,
but the woman is just
a walking glow stick.
Like she's just full of
gratitude and love and kindness.
- Yeah.
- She was just
the greatest gift.
- And you've been
in the industry for so long,
so y'all just met on "Hot in Cleveland.
- Yeah, back.
- Are you still floored?
- Oh, yes, I mean,
Betty's been amazing for,
you know, 99 years.
(chuckles)
- I know I was so mad.
'Cause I was like, really,
just shy of a hundred?
- That was, that was...
- But that's Betty.
Betty's got the best timing.
Why not send 2021 out with a bang?
Okay, see you later, I'm out.
- She's like, peace! (laughs)
- So I couldn't help but notice
that in your new lovely
book, it started here.
Like after you were here.
- It did.
We were right over there cooking,
making a crab and cheesy dip.
- Which I don't cook well, but I love
that it started there.
- You made that great dip.
- Because of you.
(both laugh)
- And then, oh yes there we are,
and then I took the leftovers
'cause I always have stuff at home too,
because I'm always
practicing before I do it.
And I took it over to Wolfie's house
and that's when Ed came by and
it all starts the whole story
of this reconnection that Ed and I had
in the last few years of his life.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah.
- That must have been hard,
I know 'cause I've gone through a divorce,
still going through divorce and it feels,
it's a weird thing, but
it feels like a death.
It feels like such a
loss, divorce in general,
and then to lose him again,
that must've been really hard.
- Yeah, it sucks.
- 'Cause it's your kids'
father too, you know?
- Yeah, but there was something
and I know so many people get mad at me
when I say that there was
a love that Ed and I had
that no one really can, but it's true,
I mean, I don't know why-
- Why do they get mad, but
that's a beautiful thing?
- Because we were both
married to other people.
But it wasn't, and it was nothing sexual.
It was nothing.
It was just, I've known the
guy since I was 20 years old,
I was a baby.
And he was just my life
for a very long time.
So I'm a little uncomfortable
talking about it,
but I'm not, because there's
nothing to be ashamed of
when you love somebody.
- Yeah.
- Love is love.
- I think there's room
to love a lot of people
and there are different types of love.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And it turned into
like a brother, sister
and I care about him so
much, still do, still do.
- Why did you call the
book "Enough Already"?
And it's, I love that "Learning
to love the way I am today".
- Because I'm done.
I'm just done judging myself.
I'm done with all the negative
talk that I give to myself
because there's enough
negative talk out there.
It's just enough already, enough!
Enough getting on the scale,
enough saying horrible
things about myself,
and just changing the
perspective, and changing
the view and the narrative.
- The narrative.
- Thank you.
And also I am enough, I'm enough.
- Yeah, and it's so.
- It's enough.
- It's so interesting 'cause
from an outsider's perspective
and just even having the
one lunch we got to share,
it was like, I literally remember leaving
and telling Ashley, I was like,
"Man, she is such a light,
she's so kind, she's so normal".
You were so cool, really...
- I thought the same thing about you.
- Well, what's funny is
rarely do you meet people,
and I don't really.
- In this business.
- We're always working and busy and busy
and rarely do I really find that.
So it's so, I had advice
actually given to me for 2022
and it was, treat yourself
how you treat others,
'cause I feel like we are
kind to people a lot often
more than to ourselves.
- Yes, unfortunately.
- Which was so crappy!
- Right, and it's not okay!
- Why do we do that?
- I don't know, I mean,
it's just I learned
from a very, very, very young
age by just the way you watch
and the way you see the way
people treat each other.
That it's just the certain
things that you're allowed to say
and not allowed to say
and not allowed to feel.
And I learned at a young age
that gaining weight was
unlovable, made me unlovable.
- Wow.
- So I'm still trying to
purge that out of my system
because it's not, that's
not true, it's just a lie.
- No, yeah, that's oh
my gosh that's so sad.
I think that's a thing in the
South that's said a lot too.
I don't know if it's everywhere.
- All over the world.
- It's definitely in the South,
but I also, I think
what I am glad about is,
I think so many things
happened to me when I was young
about my weight that I
think even at a young age,
so many things get said
that I think that's
whenever I was just like,
whatever, I'm not gonna please anyone.
- God bless you.
- I think I was lucky
it happened because before
I got in the industry,
'cause in industry you
were talking about your son
being in the industry it's
very hard, even for men.
- Yes.
- Even for men to look a certain way
and do a certain thing.
And it's just such a silly thing.
And I love the title "Enough Already".
'Cause it's very welcoming
to so many people
that have the same fight within themself,
that they're trying to overcome.
- It's hard when you
learn as a little girl
and then trying to get that out.
So for you to break that as a little girl
is something to be really proud of.
It took me a long time.
I mean, I watched my mom
not get loved by my dad
when she would gain weight.
I had an elementary school
teacher point at my belly
and say, you better watch that.
I didn't even realize I
had a body before that.
Like I had no awareness
of what I looked like.
It was just, let's have fun.
And then all of a sudden I was like,
oh, I'm supposed to look a certain way.
Oh!
- Yeah that's damaging.
- That's not okay.
- Yeah, no, you gotta be so
careful with what you say
in front of the little
ones, they're sponges.
And they retain everything, oh my gosh.
But you were married for 25 years
and something that I
love that you just said,
and I wanted to bring back.
'Cause I love that that
shared love can change,
it can be a different kind
of love, it can evolve.
And I think that that's like gotta be
an elevated emotional kind of state.
Like I don't think a lot
of people can do that
and I love that you
loved in a different way.
And I love that you've mentioned too
that you still feel his presence.
- I do, I do in so many different ways.
There was a couple of things
in the book that I write about,
really kind of woo-woo kind
of things that I'm like,
if you believe in that
great, it happened to me.
But there was something recently
that just happened to me
after I finished the book.
And I had kind of like
made this pact with Ed
that I would see a certain bird
or was it two, or was it three?
I wasn't sure whether it
was two or three birds.
And then I would know he was there.
And so I was in the bathroom
early in the morning,
I had this big picture window and I said,
oh, there's three birds, Ed, are you here?
I said, oh wait, was it two birds?
And I said, oh God, was it two or three?
So I don't know if it's you,
Ed, if you're here or not.
You know what, screw it, if you're here,
just send a whole flock of birds!
And literally, I didn't
even get that sentence
out of my mouth and a whole
flock of birds went going by.
It must have been 20, 30
birds, these little tiny birds.
And you know, they do
those waves, you see them.
That's what happened, went
by, never saw the birds again.
I'm like, okay, I got goosebumps.
It's like, oh Ed, okay cool, you're here.
- And here's the thing too,
who cares if people
believe or don't believe.
You believe and it happened.
- It made me happy.
- You had that pact with him
and it's special, yeah.
I'll tell you what, I've
never seen anything,
but I will say my child,
my daughter, River,
whenever she was a baby,
no lights were in the room,
there was nothing on,
it's not like she was staring at anything.
It was a pitch black room.
I had the white noise going,
so they'd go to sleep.
- I love that.
- Yes, and then I had her in,
and she legit was sitting
there smiling, giggling,
just laughing at something.
And I was like, I literally
said the same thing out loud.
I was like, so I don't know
if anyone's here right now,
but if you are just be kind
to my child, whoever you are.
And then I was like, and
you're cool, you can hang out.
I literally had a conversation
with maybe nothing,
but I was like, just on the off chance
she's talking to someone.
- Just be nice.
- Yes, just be nice.
Don't scare the crap out
of her is all I'm asking.
- And she was smiling so it's good.
- She was though, she was so intensely
having a moment with
something and I've never felt
I've never had anything
like that happen to me,
but it was really weird.
- There's really cool
things I write about,
a couple of things that
I write about in the book
about more instances where it's like,
okay, thanks Ed, can you just
give me a break right now?
- Yeah, we all our energy, just saying.
- Yes, yes.
- Yes.
- And our energy needs to go somewhere.
- It's still here, I like it.
We could keep talking, but
my producer's gonna kill me.
(laughs)
Mark, look, I love her.